I think the truly innovative ideas come from two places:...
...number one, culture; and number two, a process.
So, let's look at those.
By culture, I really mean the environment in which we innovate, both internally and externally.
How safe do we feel to create?
How safe do we feel to be our best selves?
We found that the culture and the environment in which we innovate have a direct correlation...
...to the amount and quality of the ideas that a group can produce.
Second, our process.
Although creating a team full of talent obviously is important,...
...the truly innovative, executable ideas that we produce are often more a result of our process...
...than the individuals who produce those ideas.
Our funnel process takes raw ideas that we come up with...
...and funnels them down using reaction and integration to create new and hybrid ideas...
...that have a level of innovation that's way more than the sum of their parts.
We found that's it's rare for an individual or group to consistently be able to produce innovative ideas on command.
So, we work hard at creating a culture that allows people to feel motivated and safe,...
...and a process that takes volumes of ideas through several steps and leads to true innovation.